If you grew up with the 1990 miniseries adaptation
of Stephen King's It, brace yourself: the
2017 film version pulls all the gore and insanity
straight from the pages of Stephen King's
blood-soaked 1986 novel.
The movie follows the seven kids in the Losers'
Club as they try to thwart an evil, clown-shaped
nightmare in the small town of Derry, Maine.
Let's take a trip down into the sewers to
look at all the Easter eggs you missed in
It.
Warning: Some spoilers ahead.
Also, clowns.
Lots of clowns.
The Pennywise doll
During the Losers' Club's first visit to the
run-down house at 29 Neibolt Street, Bill,
Eddie, and Richie get separated, and Richie
finds himself locked in literally the worst
place ever—a room full of clown dolls.
But look closely, because they aren't just
any terrifying clown dolls.
Just to the left of the spot where Pennywise
pops out stands a figure who may look familiar:
Pennywise from the 1990 miniseries, as portrayed
by Tim Curry.
Werewolf hands
In both the book and the miniseries, Richie's
main fear is werewolves, a fear he gets after
watching I Was A Teenage Werewolf at the local
theater.
So naturally, that's the shape the evil fear-sucking
clown usually takes when it appears for him.
And while there aren't any werewolves howling
at the Derry moon in the 2017 It, audiences
do get a quick glimpse of that lupophobia
during the encounter at 29 Neibolt Street.
While the monster advances on Eddie, Bill,
Richie, and Beverly, you can see werewolf
claws start to rip through its clown gloves.
It's just a quick moment, but it shows the
filmmakers were thinking of the fans even
as they were deciding to pretty much forget
about CG'ing a big goofy werewolf.
Tracker Brothers
From Eddie's Airwolf t-shirt to the bully
Belch Huggins' Anthrax tee, the kids' outfits
are all about the sweet nostalgia of childhood
in the late '80s.
Which is why one shirt in particular stands
out.
When Eddie, Richie, Stan, and Bill go looking
for Georgie in the drainage pipe in the Barrens
early in the movie, Bill's wearing a green
shirt with a nondescript round logo in the
center.
If you look closely, though, you can see that
the logo says Tracker Brothers.
In the novel, Tracker Brothers is a company
in Derry, and their factory is where grown-up
Eddie first meets Pennywise when he gets back
to Derry.
Christine
Bill isn't the only It character who boasts
a cottony Easter egg in this movie—one of
Eddie's shirts also hearkens back to King's
other works, with a design of an angry car
with what appears to be a chrome V on the
front.
If that sounds familiar, you've probably read
Christine, King's 1983 novel about a killer
car—or seen the film adaptation.
Interestingly enough, Christine also makes
an appearance in the It novel—or at least,
a red and white 1958 Plymouth Fury being driven
by a corpse shows up.
But what else could that be?
Freese's Department Store
Was every Easter egg in this movie printed
on a t-shirt?
We also see
Richie wearing a shirt proudly advertising
Freese's.
You've probably never shopped there, and for
good reason—Freese's was a departme nt store
in Bangor, Maine that operated from 1892 to
1985.
So why would Richie wear a shirt from a defunct
store that operated in a completely different
town?
Well, Bangor just happens to be Stephen King's
longtime home.
A nod to the creator of It?
Yeah, we can definitely believe that.
Silver
The movie doesn't pay any special attention
to the kids' bikes, and for the most part,
the audience won't either.
But fans of the story may have noticed one
bike in particular that plays a big part in
the original novel: Bill's silver Schwinn,
which happens to have the word "Silver" printed
on the frame.
In the book, that bike actually saves two
lives—once in the '50s, when Bill uses it
to save Eddie from an asthma attack, and once
in the '80s, when grown-up Bill drives down
the middle of traffic on a busy street to
jolt his wife out of catalepsy.
Although none of that happened in the movie,
the small detail of putting a name on Bill's
beloved bike probably wasn't lost on fans.
The Bradley Gang
The filmmakers stuck a ton of tiny details
into the background of It, but one of the
best was the mural of the Bradley Gang shootout—you
get a few glimpses of it on the brick wall
when Mike Hanlon hallucinates the burning
hands reaching through the door.
In the book, the Bradley Gang was a group
of outlaws who were killed by the Derry townsfolk
in 1929, which was the last time Pennywise
was awake before the Losers' Club confronts
him.
It's an excellent nod to the source material
for anyone paying attention, although most
people were probably pretty distracted by
the charred hands clawing at the door frame.
Deadlights
In the novel, Pennywise is an ancient cosmic
being that came into our universe because
humans have good imaginations, and all that
imagination and fear makes its food taste
good.
He's not really a clown, but clowns are scary
and good at luring children, so he kind of
sticks with it.
What he really is is something called deadlights,
which are energy thingies that usually look
like undulating orange orbs.
This guy saw them, and he went crazy.
The movie doesn't mention the deadlights at
all, because, well...
"I've never said that name out loud before,
it sounds stupid.
Call them whatever you want."
But there is one quick glimpse of the deadlights.
After Pennywise kidnaps Beverly and takes
her to his sewer lair, Beverly looks down
his throat to see three orange lights swirling
around each other.
A moment later, she's comatose and floating
in the air.
It's a giant WTF moment for anyone new to
the story, but diehard fans gave a silent
cheer.
Whether or not the cosmic side of Pennywise
is explored more deeply in part two is uncertain
as of this video, but the quick cameo of Pennywise's
true form in the first part certainly make
for a satisfying Easter egg.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!